hey everyone welcome to live coding with
Jessie I'm Jessie and I apologize for
being 7 minutes late I I had so many
things happen all at once right when I
was going to start so really sorry it
got a couple emails from work and had to
respond to those and I've I'm getting
errors when I try to commit and when I
tried to start the stream the button to
start the stream was was like grayed out
and I I couldn't get it to start it
turns out I just had to refresh the page
and it worked but anyway I'm sorry that
was really late apologies for that but I
was kind of freaking out beforehand
because my the project wouldn't wouldn't
run at all so I mean that was that was a
big deal because we wouldn't really have
much of a show if that was the case all
right let me check I'm gonna check the
live chat really quick because there's a
lot in there
okay all right so for those of you who
haven't seen this show before I'm gonna
do some coding and then I'm gonna answer
some questions and then do coding and
then answer some questions and I'll
break it up with a timer so I'm gonna do
a 25 minute timer which I'm going to
start now and I think maybe I should
move I'm gonna move the timer to one of
my other screens and we'll just leave
the code on this screen let me make this
bigger so y'all can see today's
livestream is only gonna be around an
hour long which is pretty close to what
our normal is but I do have to go
somewhere shortly after that today so
gotta make sure I don't lose track of
time all right
so I think that should be big enough for
everyone to see
just to show you what what has gone on
and what some of the errors were I
upgraded to next version 6
I believe it's 6.0 1 is the official
version so if anybody is upgrading your
react or your next projects to 6 watch
out for this it may not affect all of
you but if you have a babel RC file and
you have these presets the presets need
to be arrays so what I had was I had
just strings and not arrays and it would
not start the server at all it would try
to start and then it would exit so that
would my issue was simply IDs just
needed to be a race so if you're having
some similar issues
try putting all your values for your
presets and your babel others RC file
into make him erase now I'm also getting
another error so I thought that fixed
the problem but when I wanted to commit
really quickly before the stream so that
you all didn't get the same error if you
tried to load this project but my tests
failed and I think it's it's a similar
issue so I didn't get to completely fix
this before I started the stream but it
says it couldn't find preset and
relative to the directory users Jessie
our projects trances can react so this
is why I'm assuming that we we have this
file here we have tests we have presets
and so I'm wondering if this is also an
issue and we're gonna try we need to
troubleshoot this first before we move
on otherwise I'm just gonna push this
same error up to github and I don't want
to do that I'd rather fix it so this is
gonna be CSS hopefully we can fix this
in a minute or two if I can't fix it in
a minute - I'll just hold off and I
won't commit anything and I'll fix it
later and then commit all my stuff later
but if we can fix it quickly I think
it'll be better more rides if I never
listen to different rate all right so
it's looking for before there all right
so let's see
Oh quick
it's
yeah
okay so Harshit said that he had the
same issue all right awesome hard
let me check out says check out the
babel RC in JSA f so let's go let me
pull over a browser window and we'll do
this together so some of you I'm sure
have heard me talk about this project
before but Carson and I and Niki
JavaScript er have been working on a
side project called JavaScript AF so
this is where we're gonna go right now
to get the fix for our issue so I need
to go into the front-end correct and if
you check this out and github before
check it out again and it's a lot easier
to contribute now it's all in one repo
the backend the front-end are no longer
separated all right let me see the
difference here let's get rid of that
glad I don't have to go through that I
wasn't looking forward to it
okay let's copy make sure yes
just don't copy style confinement stuff
okay yeah I didn't yeah I didn't get the
style component stuff so whoops
and I need one more of those
I believe am I good maybe I didn't need
one more all right
I was kind of one two three four five
she goes here and then six go slowly up
there seven all right yeah that should
work okay let's start that and let's
rerun this so I'm gonna do yarn CM and
then I'm gonna give it the retry flag
hopefully this will work and then we can
get started on our CSS so if you were
here for just the CSS stuff sorry for
the wait it looks like it's working now
and it's gonna happen no it still failed
I hopefully I didn't get the same error
as for finding invalid property of the
fault
yes all right did I mess it up
mmm
alright let me verify that this actually
is still loading the page and if it is I
think we'll just move on to that
localhost let's go
all right so if this is still loading I
think we may just go on to the CSS okay
all right so I'll work on that later on
if anybody is having similar problems
and is really interested on how we fix
that just ask me later on and hopefully
I'll have that fixed later today okay so
here's the page we're gonna go to and we
were working on this a little yesterday
but we're gonna work on it from a
different angle we're gonna do the CSS
we were doing it JavaScript and data
stuff yesterday so today we'll work on
the CSS so this would be a good stream
if you're kind of new maybe you're not
that great with react or JavaScript but
you do know CSS or you're at least
learning it then we can see I think I
had its didn't have education faculty I
don't know if I have this data linked up
we'll find out in a second if not I can
switch to a different Department yep
don't have it all right so let's go with
oh I know I know who's English English
faculty there we are
me too okay harsh it says I need two new
dependencies Babel core and Babel just
wish the versions in there okay I'll
grab those in a little bit okay so this
is the page as it is right now it
doesn't look great and so just a quick
recap of how we got to this point we
created some cards we used some pre-made
components and then added our own stuff
as well and then we're just pulling some
data using graph QL
we're pulling some data from a wordpress
installation and we're getting a lot of
markup and then we use some regular
expressions to pull out the pieces of
the markup that we wanted and this is
what we have and we have a couple
problems here so the big problem is we
have these images and they're obviously
different shapes and sizes so what we
need to do is create a way to display
this that will look good no matter what
shape and size image we have okay the
hard should I see I see you have the fix
I just want to get do a little CSS stuff
because I I advertise the stream as CSS
so I don't want to get too far off right
now maybe I'll try it a little later on
in the stream
I'll do the fix all right so here's what
I'm thinking
we can maybe actually you know what we
had this issue before we had this issue
on a different project let's take a look
at a different UI we created a little
less than than a year ago so let's go
here to khattak addicts comm and this
was our first project we did on the
stream we had the same issue with really
similar components similar similar data
and so this is what we had we tried to
go with a cart approach but because we
have different size and shapes in terms
of images it wouldn't work so we ended
up going with these rows instead
and also we wanted to make sure that all
of our text was aligned properly so we
obviously couldn't put the images on
this side we had to move them that this
side I think this is probably the model
that we ought to go with so what we'll
do is we're gonna we're gonna switch
around the mark up a little bit to make
it easier to apply our styles but we're
basically gonna follow this and we may
even come in and grab some styles that
we used here so maybe like this little
line here might not be a bad idea to
just pull the Styles instead of trying
to recreate it but unless anyone has
objections I think this is the route
that that we're gonna go with so since
we already did all the work to do this
you know what why not use that as the
basis for what we're gonna do here it'll
be nice and create some consistency
between two different sites that are
both University sites for Franciscan
University so always good that provide a
familiar user experience across you you
know different sites okay so let's look
at the actual file the mark-up for this
to see what we need to change because I
think this is gonna take a bit more than
just CSS we'll have to move around some
things in the markup so I'm gonna leave
these pages up I'm not gonna close them
out since we'll probably be editing them
later on to fix our error but right now
let's go to I thought I had these pages
up maybe I don't
[Music]
faculty list that's not it I just open
it up here no my my node modules folder
got open
that's the worst and you have to scroll
for three days
um okay where are my components that's
what we want to be components and here's
our new component that we've created
just in the last few days and that's
that list card item and if we turn this
into a list row item we'll probably end
up changing the name I'm just gonna
leave it for now but here's what we'll
do right off the bat let's check out
no this isn't it faculty list item
that's what it is it wasn't Lascar died
in this faculty list items so sorry
about that let's see okay yeah this
looks way more familiar I was scrolling
through that component like I don't
remember any of this from from yesterday
all right so we're not gonna have a card
anymore so let's get rid of what we're
doing here in terms of setting up a card
and let's switch it out and for now
let's just add divs so I'm just gonna
select whoa didn't realize there wasn't
oh I see what it is let's add some divs
I need to go way up here to card and
change this to do and let's make sure we
do the same here we'll do do alright so
this will be our outermost container and
then we have some things in here like
card actions I'm actually really
interested to see what things look like
if we just remove the outer card and we
leave the other things in there oops I
capitalized Dave I don't know what I was
thinking and so we don't need card so
let's just import card actions apart
content so let's just see what it does
we should have gotten Auto refresh it
looks like there we are nice okay this
is what I was hoping would happen so
we've actually kept a lot of the styles
here like for for the button here that's
that's exactly what I wanted so that's
good news
you know one thing that we're not
getting though that we did get before is
we had a we had more info showing up
let's see why we're not getting that
info also I don't know if you notice
this I installed we had a talk yesterday
about how my imports are a mess and so I
went ahead and did a setting so I
upgraded my Visual Studio code and I
notice there is a new setting to where
you could if you turned it on it would
auto organize all your imports the only
problem is that it also adds semicolons
which we have set for there not to be
semicolons so I I don't know
so my in court it seems like my imports
can either be organized with semicolons
or not organized without them I'm hoping
that it'll just get Auto formatted once
it gets committed and then it'll be okay
all right so why are we busy are we
missing some of this
yeah we should we should be getting the
title right in there and for some reason
we're not I mean we're still getting the
image obviously unless for some reason
it's the font is white and I just can't
see it would be odd but I guess it's
worth checking
okay it it looks like yeah we're not
getting me yeah it should be here should
be in this pizza we're not getting sorry
that the dev tools font is probably
insanely small not string that up again
okay so here where there should be
content there's not
all right let's play around with this
just for a second to see why this isn't
coming in still nothing okay there we
are so we got something this time why is
there so much going on this time all
right so now let me try to put this back
in because this should be what we want
basically where the title gives us an
array of two values and we don't want to
we want one okay
great that works not really sure what
was going on there but this gives us
what we want and it gives us what we
need to continue on with our styling so
in terms of markup let's let's try to
make this a little bit easier for to
handle with our CSS so let's grab this
div that is our image and let's throw it
down here below our card actions it's
this word now we want it down here so
we're gonna throw it down below here and
I'm gonna get rid of this we were
keeping it to test it out but now that
we're not gonna use a card I don't think
we will use it that'll just clean up our
component a bit
we have about two more minutes before I
do some questions from the live chat so
hang in there if you have some questions
and okay there we are so now we have our
images below which in in terms of the
flow of you know the this site is will
obviously be a left to right site that
makes more sense with the markup okay
now let's get into some of the styling
that we could do we have a few options
we could style you know completely
custom with CSS well we could maybe take
advantage of some of things we have
available to us with material you I I
think I want to just do some regular CSS
styles though so what we'll do is we
will we already have some class here
class of card on everything and did we
did we wrap this in anything else we did
not great but what we did do in our
faculty list component where we're
pulling this in oops that's our faculty
this query let's get rid of that for now
here's our faculty list component what
we did was we put our all our faculty
stuff in this masonry layout this
masonry flat with the grid so we want to
you know stop doing that and we'll keep
this container
we'll take out masonry right and then
for our grid we can keep the grid and
that won't really be an issue if we want
but what we need I guess we need a grid
container what we need to do is get rid
of this and let's let's bring back and
just call this but let's say that see
what happens I think we're gonna need a
container though for a grid also we're
gonna get it's not gonna like that we
took out masonry
oh maybe it just automatically took it
out for me awesome okay so now you see
these all are a hundred percent of the
width of the container so that's what we
want it these are now rows okay so
that's a that's a good first step next
step after we take a little break for
questions is going to be getting these
images over here and getting them to be
not quite so large once we get those
over there then we can work on how to
display this information and and the
most attractive way possible so let me I
guess I don't have to do anything on the
screen let me go over to the chat and
I'm gonna start up at the top I'm gonna
scroll through look for any questions
I'm gonna set a five-minute timer and
we'll see how much I can get through
five minutes and I need to make sure I
keep an eye on the clock I have my phone
here okay it's 11:35 my time 11:35 a.m.
so gotta make sure I don't go really
don't go past noon too much so so what
as it was a feast for days asked what is
the age of consent for CSS in the US is
this obviously a joke but that's that's
good one see
so see a lot of you saying hello hey
everybody
we have someone I is it's aya Z if I'm
mispronouncing that please let me know
it says hi I'm new welcome thanks for
watching and thanks for letting me know
you're here in the chat is si I don't
know something about coding okay so if
you're beginner feel free to ask
questions I'll do my best to answer them
and explain what I'm doing there's a lot
of other people in the chat that are
very helpful lord dragon as how often
does this happen and I'm assuming Lord
dragons talking about the errors and
things that were happening yeah it's I
don't know I mean errors like that I
mean that was pretty serious the whole
site was like wouldn't start that's not
that often but you know things do mess
up so almost all these things don't go
exactly according to plan so these these
are I will say these are real projects
that I'm doing for my employer so I
don't rehearse any of this so when I
mess up we fix it together here on the
stream and I I mess up a lot so that's
that's what you get here so it's not
exactly a well planned out tutorial but
it is an authentic glimpse into what I
do as a my titles front-end developer
but we do back in at times as well let's
see alright Phoenix says the
notification from YouTube came on time
today which is awesome yesterday had an
issue where Phoenix didn't get the
notification or didn't get it till
really late so I'm glad you got it I
asked us how can I get started with
coding I as I think if you go to free
code camp org and go through some of
those exercises that's a really easy way
to get started
it's easy in terms of setup you just
need a browser and an internet
connection and you could start there so
if you just work your way through some
of those challenges and free code camp
and then their lessons I think that'll
give you an idea for you know maybe do
you like it this is something you want
to pursue further and then you know you
can keep going further on and progress
like that yeah John says another bit of
advice to new people put your seat belt
on it's a ride a knowledge ride I like
that one
uh JJ solo says looks like a hacker and
not a web coder haha I didn't realize it
looked like a hacker so I don't know if
that's a compliment or not but let's
take it as a compliment so evidently I
look like a really awesome hacker
Christian asks what is the difference
between material UI and bootstrap yet so
hardship gives an answer here material
UI is based on Google's material design
framework and material UI also is
designed to work in with react
components so bootstrap on the other
hand is its own as don't style and it's
also designed to work on almost say like
let's say sites websites that don't have
a particular JavaScript framework it or
library like angular react to you so a
bootstrap is easier to use for just a
plain JavaScript HTML CSS site although
I do believe there are versions out
there that can be used with things like
angular and react alright so I didn't
get to all the questions but I will
after our next session is over or I will
at least try to get to everything right
now I just started another 25-minute
Pomodoro session we're gonna get back to
the code and let's see oh did you all
y'all heard the alarm from oh I forgot
my my laptop speakers must still be on
and my headphones which are normally in
my laptop or in my phone so that I don't
waste any computing power on running
Spotify alright so our next step then is
to display this on this side over here
so let's just do a little bit of work
right here in dev tools so I think it's
it's always very useful to do working
dev tools by the way if you haven't
already done so it might not be a bad
idea to check out the the latest in
what's available in dev tools so at one
of the sessions at the Google i/o
conference they did a
on the new stuff in in dev tools so you
that's on the Google Developers YouTube
channel so check that out definitely
worthwhile a lot of cool tools so I'm
still not familiar enough with them to
use them yet but I think I might need to
watch the talk again in practice but
definitely some good stuff so let's see
what we can do here and here's what I'm
gonna try first
let's give let's let's try using a bit
of flexbox here okay unfortunately well
are we already using flex nice
let's give it a display flex okay and
then let's set my on the top oops I
don't want to be I'm one step up from
where I want to be I actually want to be
down here so we'll give this a display
flex hey already looking like a little
better here so we'll give this a display
flex and let's see okay so by default
let's see flex direction
let's just go these are the options we
have we could do a column which is what
we had before we don't want call them
reverse which flips the site flips the
content and then we could GU row or row
reverse so we want row which we'd
defaulted to anyway so we're gonna go
with that but that just gives you an
idea of your options and let's see just
justified content here's some some other
options we can go with so you can see we
can Center our content and flex it so
it's it's not actually that great to use
right now because there's not a whole
lot of space right but what what I would
like to do is set things to the left
okay there'll be a line left and then
let's go down to this and for this one
let's say justify self and we'll go
rights that should have done that maybe
there's just not enough space not yeah
it should have adjusted interesting
I got a I shouldn't have to do this yeah
i what am I doing wrong just fat content
okay
the first two times inside the same diff
okay so John's saying the first two need
to be inside the same div all right so
that's messing things up alright let's
go ahead and adjust the mark-up a bit so
that we can get a better result and then
also let's do the the mark-up first so
down here within our faculty list item
component which now or is gonna be a row
basically we need to say have our card
actions and our card content in the same
div so let's just create a div here and
class name equals classes that's Louis
we'll call it text content and that'll
give us something to use as a class here
and when we need it down here yeah this
is where we need our end all right
is that it let's see
I think so alright let's go back over
here we can see already this is aligning
much more nicely for us so now we only
have two kind of sub groupings here
within our list actually what's this
happen there we are there's the div um
I'm looking at so within this div we
only have two sections two divs now
better direct children and that's better
that's what we want so let's go back to
here to this one and so if you hear the
vibrating noise I'm getting a phone call
but I don't know who it is I'm not gonna
answer it so what I want to do justify
self and I wanted to see if that would
work it looks like it's still not
working so it looks like John had some
other things see what he said between Oh
excellent
John you are awesome so we can use this
justify content space between to
basically get the the effect we want so
let's take what we've done here and
apply it in our actual project and let's
let's see how it looks on all of these
next step after that we'll be tackling
you know these images we need to make a
the maximum height to the images the
width is gonna be okay and as long as
it's not outrageous you know any width
will do but we do need a maximum height
so let's go ahead and do that I think
the way let's see display for X
sticks are just like content space
between okay I can remember that so what
did we name this outer div I believe
our classes card yeah which we had yes
with 100% on so now with our with 100%
we're gonna add this now I do have to
say this is gonna look a little bit
different than normal CSS so I had
anticipated we would be using a regular
stylesheet but after looking at the
markup and working with it I think this
will be the better way to go so this is
actually using CSS as JavaScript
essentially this is JavaScript object
but in terms of what we call things and
the values we give them it's gonna be
pretty much the same as normal CSS so
let's go with display flex and we had
what was it I already forgot it I
thought I could remember it Oh flex
direction Rho which we don't need
because it's gonna be there by default
so let's leave that out and then we need
justify content C and we're gonna camel
case because we're in JavaScript land
right now and in hyphens mean minus
signs and we're gonna do the space
between we can leave the hyphen in but
in this case because we put it in single
quotes which makes it a string in so
that's okay all right so we have that
and then if you remember we made another
div and we called that it was text
content right so we're gonna say for our
text content actually do we need to do
anything with that no we don't and we
don't need that okay great so we
actually don't need this which is
wonderful
less whoops I got rid of the comma that
I needed let's save that and then I'm
gonna do a hard refresh or just a
fresh and that'll just get rid of
anything that we had left over here in
chrome so that it doesn't interfere and
we know for sure that this is our stuff
that we put in our project and not our
test stuff in chrome and nice one thing
I don't understand that why this is
happening but we keep getting alternate
order for this data so I think maybe at
the later time what I'm gonna have to
address that but not bad not bad so
let's let's shrink these down let's at
least see what what the height is for
these looks like 300 pixels so let's see
if we put a max height on these images
let's see what we get so once again
we'll do it in dev tools first we may
even be able to do it on the detail
image you let's let's do that since we
can grab it from from the tag name and
apply it everywhere and let's set max
height 300 pixels whoa let's get our
image here
alright let's try it again let's put our
300 pixels here okay much better much
much better okay so it's it's still not
gonna be the most visually appealing
thing so at some point it might be nice
to go in and what we would need really
is to look up or in our photo archive if
we actually have photos that are more
like this for these professors and then
if we don't we'll need to get our
photographers to set up appointments
with these professors to take you know
professional photo that would give us
what we need for kind of for
Standardization of the site but doing it
this way does allow us to have various
sizes of images and it doesn't throw off
our entire layout so I think we're gonna
go with this for now the only thing I'd
like to add is that kind of horizontal
line in here so we'll do that and then
once again we've lost the we've lost
some of our data so yeah that's that's a
problem for later on
I'm not going to tackle that during this
stream okay so let's add this style up
now into our component so we're gonna go
down here Oh actually no we're getting
we're gonna need to add some CSS in here
into a CSS file so what we'll do it
we'll do it in here
so in our faculty list component I
believe we're already bringing in styles
here's our Styles so let's make a CSS
page this faculty list okay yeah so what
we want
actually let's let's do it like this I
want to keep whatever styles we have in
faculty and then I want to see if we can
bring in another style sheet and we'll
call that faculty list and this is gonna
seem like overkill right now but we'll
probably end up adding styles to this so
don't don't worry about it and if it
does end up being overkill dev - style
sheets will we can refactor hmm sorry
about the yawn alright so we need to
actually create this so we're gonna go
into our static styles and we're gonna
add another page and we're gonna still
call this faculty list dot CSS and now
see it's open and we're gonna we're
gonna say in our faculty list dot CSS
anything that's in this detail oops and
what's what is a detailed view image
element and it's an image we're gonna
MIT set it at a max height of 300 pixels
and let's save that we'll see see what
happens here let's give it a refresh to
get rid of what we've just done here all
right wonderful so that's been pooled in
oh and for a second we actually had the
data that we wanted and what happened
what happens happening weird and in this
component so at least we have hmm there
were images looking better better than
they were and you can see this CSS has
now successfully been imported
here and if we we look we can see in dev
tools that it's pulling that from
faculty list dot CSS see we can see it's
right here and we still as well have our
other other styles being applied that
were already there as well as our Styles
here and then any inline styles that we
may want to use those are applied as
well so we have a lot of different
levels of styles going on okay Harshit
said check the console which is a great
idea to see what what may be going on
here did not match okay it says warning
prop dangerously set enter HTML did not
match server client interesting so it
looks like that is why I'm getting this
I said I
yeah all right so something's wrong with
the way I'm pulling in this title
content so it looks like it's pulling it
in initially but then it's taking it out
because it's not matching what we'll
divers on the server so anyway we'll
we'll tackle that let me check how much
time we have in this comodoro session
okay about only about five more minutes
so basically at this point I'm just
gonna go I'm gonna do some more
questions because I need to end the
stream in a few minutes anyway so if I
were getting all the data here that I
would like to have then we may do a bit
more styling just to make sure
everything lines up and we would add
that horizontal in here but basically
it's gonna end up looking somewhat like
this which I think will look pretty nice
the only adjustment to make them may be
made is like right now compared to the
text the images are quite large you
might not be a bad idea to maybe shrink
these and do max height of maybe 250
pixels that way more faculty members can
be displayed at once you know you could
see them on one screen there wouldn't be
the oldest space here so that I mean
there there are some things that
definitely could be done to improve it
so right now I need to hurry through the
rest of this live chat so normally I
like to take my time and answer all the
questions but unfortunately today I
cannot and I actually completely forgot
I had somewhere to go until I already
started the stream and then I I got a
message on my phone that I had that I
had an employment and I panicked for a
second and thought when is it when is it
and but I I still had time to stream
just a quick one all right I'm trying to
figure out where I left off in the chat
okay the Stevens here Steven says hey
hey how's it going
deepak says thank you so much for
sharing your time with us all you're
welcome well I mean that you all are
sharing your time as well so I
appreciate that
appreciate you all watching in and
helping me so don't this is definitely
not a one-sided thing here
well Michael said why not set max height
of road of to 300 to scale everything
down yeah I guess I could have tried
that although when we tried to set the
container did for this image down to 300
the image is just kind of bled out
anyway so anyway I mean this this works
as it is I suppose but but had I seen
that message earlier I probably would
have tried it oh and then John said the
same thing set it on the outer div group
and let me try to pronounce this it's
gee you are you Raj guru rush I'm gonna
say guru Raj let me know if that's not
how to pronounce it says please make
shopping cart app with angular 6 and
nodejs and latest material design I
haven't worked with angular for a long
long time let alone angular 6 so I don't
think I'll be making that anytime soon
so if anybody else has anything like
that they're working on with egular
please let us know
see
Michael creo says dr. John Homs yes we
have a dr. John homes or homes or
whatever you want to pronounce it I
don't know
okay Michael good thinking on that
michael says the faculty right now are
being brought in by their faculty ID and
so that's how they're ordered but they
should be ordered by last name
alphabetically so we will do that
actually I need to check what the
current order is on the main website
that's that's live the one that will be
replaced and see if they actually are an
alphabetic order there or if there's a
different order I hope itself abetik oh
I don't want to do a custom order for
everyone all right looks like there's
two more questions and then I have to be
finished Matthew says what do you
recommend if my job discourages asking
for any mentorship in my programming
skills I hear that it's really key to
help help me grow but my boss wants me
to be a 100% independent what do I do
I would say that the best thing that you
could do maybe is find information that
shows how much mentoring will help you
and really how being 100% independent
will make you less productive because I
definitely believe it will so I don't
offhand know of any studies or
information that I can point you to but
I'm sure it's out there so I would maybe
find that share that with your boss I
mean you you know your boss better than
I do of course so I don't know the best
way to approach him with that
information you may not want to just
confront him with it maybe you wanted to
slip in little comments here and there
to warm him up I don't really know but
you know you you want to show your boss
how this will make you a better employee
because that's probably what he's
worried about you know and then if you
can convince him of that then he should
be okay with with mentorship and if he
isn't still okay with it then then come
ask me and we can think about a strategy
for the next
Phoenix says hey Jesse just an update on
my 30 days 30 sites it's going good but
it looks like I am doing 30 days 30
landing pages ha ha hey well it's it's
still coding still coding every day
okay that's CSS file you created was
there a period in front of that class
attribute and in from the image or I
don't understand that
where was it thoughtfully CSS no no
period because the actual name of the
elements is detailed view image right so
we can see here the detailed view image
so we're not targeting a class we're
targeting in elements so I mean this
technically is completely okay I believe
in html5 it became okay
don't I'm not sure that that's exactly
when but so this wouldn't pass like I
don't know what are those HTML
certification things you know depending
on your version but browsers browsers
can handle this but then we go to use it
with CSS we need to treat it just like
we would let say a div where we wouldn't
put a period in front of the div so
hopefully that that answers your
question hopefully I'm understanding it
correctly okay thank you so much for
joining me thank you for putting up with
my lateness at the beginning and the
errors that I had to deal with and I
died for sure have to go right now if I
make it to my appointment on time I had
a great time and a great week with you
all and I can't wait to come back next
week and start streaming again so until
then have a wonderful weekend